careful consideration when filming the
live action pieces
is absolutely critical where does the
live action
end and the computer graphics begin
disguising
that transition is to me one of the
biggest challenges hi i'm todd vazzuri a
visual effects artist
and this is vfx support
[Music]
rahat asks texas switch alert do music
videos with christopher walken dancing
count and this is the music video from
fat boy slim
weapon of choice directed by spike jones
what is a texas switch
texas switch is a gag an on-set gag
where a stunt person or stunt performer
gets switched out in the middle of one
seamless shot
with the actor typically this is done
with a stunt performer
doing an elaborate stunt in front of the
camera falling or hiding behind a set
piece
and emerging from that set piece
is the actor in the exact same clothing
and everything
pretending like they just did this
amazing stunt christopher walken who
was a trained dancer does a lot of his
own dancing but there are certain
acrobatic moves that he couldn't
actually pull off
so there's a switch there between let's
call them a stunt dancer
and christopher walken and when the
stunt dancer
falls and tumbles out of frame
christopher walken was sitting there
and waiting for just the right moment to
pounce up and you see his
face the effect is that it's one fluid
movement
and the illusion is created but that
isn't just the only
texas switch in that video a third to
last shot when
the character is flying around in the
hotel lobby this
very elaborate shot of the character
swooping down toward camera leaves frame
the character
falls through frame and then christopher
walken emerges
and i think that's actually a double
texas switch i think it's one
stunt performer on wires there's another
performer waiting to drop and go through
frame
and christopher walken is waiting to
emerge at the very end
so there's a lot of gems in that video
go watch it
20 something more asks anyone have any
suggestions for movies
very of their time but with solid
effects could be vfx or practical
just looking for some cool stuff to
watch some of the films that really
inspired me
and still the work holds up really well
is 1933's king kong
combining live action with animation and
1941's
citizen kane nobody was doing miniature
work on that level
with that kind of flexibility and
fidelity
moving the camera through bits of
miniature to have scene transitions
using deep focus those movies are a gold
mine of
the techniques that were available at
that time and also
were revolutionary for that time one
little gem that
is not on a lot of people's radars is
darby o'gill and the little people
it's a disney movie from 1959
that has some of the most astounding
forced perspective work
that has ever been put on film even to
this day alfred hitchcock
loved using camera tricks and visual
effects one of my favorite
movies of his is north by northwest
particularly because
of all of the invisible visual effects
that he uses in the film
there are some establishing shots that
they keep cutting back to of the
villain's lair at the end of the movie
is a complete matte painting there are
tons of matte paintings in this movie he
wanted
a flare to certain shots of
buildings of mount rushmore that you
literally could not capture with the
camera there was a particularly great
run in 1982
for three films that are very very
different but had
amazing uh creature and practical
effects
uh one i want to point out is the dark
crystal directed by
jim henson and frank oz absolutely
stunning
puppet work environment work and
opticals and miniatures and net
paintings
everything that was available at that
time is thrown into that movie and it is
an absolutely beautiful movie
and worth studying the same year
poltergeist
which was the first ilm production that
was not a lucasfilm
uh production the work in poltergeist
serving a very different purpose than
say the work into dark crystal
is remarkable also in 1982
is john carpenter's the thing which has
some
amazing creature effects by rob boutin
and
combined with the location photography
uh and the stage photography where you
don't really even know
where you are and how seamlessly that
all works
the creatures in the thing are still
terrifying and still are just
absolutely exceptional and add so
much to that movie even though it won
the oscar for
best visual effects in 1989 i have to
save the abyss
the abyss took every single technique
that was available
to the filmmakers and put that on the
screen
with amazing fidelity and had
the fully computer generated pseudo pod
that enters the oil rig
which was designed by cameron to be
a sequence that if the effect did not
work
he could lift it from the movie and the
movie would still work another movie
from the 90s that i think
people may overlook is death becomes ur
yes another oscar winner for visual
effects but
the way zemeckis used
computer graphics in that film was not
necessarily for creatures or
environments
it was for body horror and the work
in that movie advancing upon what he had
ex
learned on forrest gump and what ilm
and ken ralston developed for that film
they took it to an extreme on
death becomes or also has a great texas
switch in it finally
another movie that's worth studying is
uh bram stoker's dracula
which came at a time when digital was
just taking off
as a technique to add computer graphics
or digital compositing
but francis ford coppola specifically
wanted to make a film
that used techniques that could have
been used 40 or 50 years previous to
that forced perspective
double exposures experimentations with
frame rates
filming in reverse filming things on
their side
so that your perspective is different
and gravity changes
in a way that you don't expect building
sets on their sides brand stockers
dracula
highly highly recommended wonderful
movie bacon hot dogs
asks watching the queen's gambit and i'm
always in awe of these time period
series
not only the clothes and hair but the
cars and buildings are all on point
did they build an entire las vegas from
or is cgi just that good nowadays yeah
computer graphics and visual effects
they're really good in fact the opening
shot the establishing shot
where the big graphic comes up it says
las vegas 1966
is entirely computer graphics i believe
that helicopter shot going over the las
vegas strip
that cuts to a tracking shot of the lead
character walking in the courtyard of
the hotel
we follow the character going in through
the lobby and it's actually
this beautiful uninterrupted over two
minute long shot
which has a lot of invisible visual
effects scattered throughout
but at the beginning of the shot you
look over
uh over the main character and you see
the strip you see
signage you see cars you see uh people
in
period appropriate costumes the area
directly surrounding the actress
and the front lobby that's all uh a set
piece that's all a location that has
been set dressed with
period-appropriate cars and extras in
appropriate costumes and garb
but everything beyond that is a set
extension all of the major signs
the lamp posts the cars and the
buildings and the sky itself
is all computer graphics and one thing
in particular about
queen's gambit and some of these other
prestige tv
shows that are period pieces or set in
fantastical worlds
the line between the literal quality of
the visual effects
of tv and film that's just gone
now they can actually create these
synthetic environments of whatever
period piece it is to their exact art
directed specifications
rather than relying on a single shot of
stock footage it's super exciting
patrick willems asks i've always
wondered
how do they match the film stock and
grain for cg
elements composited into footage shot on
35 millimeter
what patrick is really asking about is
the
idea of film grain when elements are
shot on film
and on digital cameras you get a similar
type of thing it's not exactly film
grain
but you get digital noise when you add
synthetic elements on top of anything
that's photographed
how do you match that exact pattern of
film grain or digital noise to the
background we get the actual cameras
that were used
during the film's production and we film
a bunch of test patterns
in front of various colored blank pieces
of cardboard
under different lighting conditions
using all of the film stocks that were
used on the particular show
or all the digital cameras that were
used on the show in the different
lighting conditions
then we take all of that pristine
footage of
nothing but film grain and we use it to
generate
our noise pattern that will be matching
what has actually been photographed we
can then use that to create
grain profiles and add it to just the
dinosaur or just the robot
so that it all blends in seamlessly with
the rest of the shot
jacob earl asks the mandalorian looked
so good
because it was rear projection some of
the shots were
achieved with rear projection but it's
not your grandpa's
projection it's an evolution of
projection techniques
that is really remarkable and to me is
one of the most exciting things that's
going on in cinema and visual effects
uh today since the beginning of cinema
there have been projection techniques
used to
simulate worlds and situations that
can't
really exist in front of the camera
front projection rear projection
which usually involves a projector
projecting imagery onto a screen or onto
the actors or onto
special screens and capturing all of
that imagery
at once to make it seem like these two
disparate things are happening at the
exact same time
and the mandalorian takes it to the next
level ilm stagecraft technique
which it utilizes led screens to
completely surround the actors
is a leap forward in projection
technology
and it's not just the led screens which
are super bright and super crisp and
super accurate
that is making this look so authentic
it's the real time computer graphics
that are being projected behind there
when you use rear projection in the
classic sense you have a static screen
and you have a static projector that may
have footage
with a camera moving in it but all of
that is
fixed and therefore it limits the amount
of motion and flexibility you have
when you're filming your actors in front
of that screen
what the mandalorian and stagecraft does
that's different is
it's a live computer graphics world and
it's tied
into the motion picture camera so when
the motion picture camera moves around
the imagery behind the actors is moving
appropriately
so you're getting proper parallax you're
getting proper perspective
and it opens up possibilities with
camera movement
and experimentation that you just
couldn't have before
kevin asks how is it that jurassic park
was made in 1993 and still looks better
than
every film that uses cg in 2019
well that's an arguable statement but
i think i understand the sentiment of
what kevin is going for right here
when jurassic park was in production at
the start of production
they thought the large-scale dinosaurs
were going to be handled with
stop-motion animation
supervised by phil tippett and in the
middle of production
the computer graphics team at ilm said
we're going to try to make a fully
digital t-rex for all of the full body
shots
and that is what made it in the movie at
the dawn of
basically modern computer graphics there
were only i think
60 or 65 fully digital shots
in jurassic park each of which had to be
designed
to the letter every single moment every
single
beat had to be completely planned out
ahead of time because
of how much work and effort would have
to go into it we can't just throw out a
dozen shots in this sequence
we cannot just create all this volume
in the time allotted with technology
that is being built
as the train is going it's a little bit
different now
where there's literally 1500 to 2000
visual effects shots
in major modern blockbusters i'd
recently watched jurassic park with my
kids
and it still holds up it totally does
the job the shot design
is absolutely amazing if you look very
carefully at those shots in jurassic
park
each of them have a beginning middle and
end each of them have a reason for being
there of connective tissue
from one bit of sequence to the next bit
of sequence your original point kevin is
arguable
but i think you're reacting to the
amazing shot design of jurassic park
eric alba asks what do you think was the
single best vfx shot or sequence in a
film
tv or a spot this year i'm gonna
revert to 2019 1917
by sam mendes was absolutely
extraordinary to have the audacity to
basically make an almost an entire movie
an uninterrupted shot
you're following these characters with
these steadicam-esque
shots right over their shoulders you are
right there with them
there's nowhere to hide there's nowhere
to duck as part of cinematic vocabulary
we are constantly expecting a cut
and when those cuts don't come it builds
tension the work that was done to get
those to look like
they were all one take was extraordinary
crazy
huge set extensions and the stitching
of different takes seamlessly right in
front of your eyes
most audiences just watched that and
just believe what was happening in front
of them
when there were these dramatic synthetic
transitions to make it seem like one
interrupted shot
lisa mcrae asks i have a dumb question
for vfx peeps
do studios ever have people that do
photoshop edits
frame by frame is that a thing the
answer is yes
these amazing digital artists
do paint frame by frame some may look at
that and go you know i've dabbled in
photoshop i've used the clone tool i can
make a still frame look really amazing
i can paint out a prop that i don't like
in the set
that's great you did a great job now
understand that
motion pictures are 24 frames per second
that paintwork that you did
has to be completely consistent from one
frame to the next
24 frames in a second and most shots are
three
four five seconds long you've got a
giant challenge so every single paint
stroke that you did
for the frame that you really like you
now have to mimic for the next frame
and for the next frame and sometimes the
camera move makes that a little bit
easier
with motion blur and parallax and things
like that
and sometimes it makes it a lot harder
so
all around the world there are talented
paint artists
whose job it is to remove props to
remove
wires to remove entire actors to remove
set pieces
to remove the reflections of the camera
crew
in a mirror that accidentally got into
shot sometimes we can use procedural
methods to get rid of those things
like painting certain still frames and
tracking them in
but other times it requires frame by
frame painting
and these paint artists are absolutely
amazing and i
my hats are off to them because it is
very hard
jessica chandler asks question for vfx
folks
if i have a handgun firing in rapid
succession should the muzzle flash be
the same each time
or should each shot produce a slightly
different flash muzzle flashes
i've done many over my career
and there is an art and science
to muzzle flashes some of the movies
that i
look at for visual reference
are the movies where the filmmakers
really wanted to make a statement with
their muzzle flashes movies like brian
de palma scarface
or john mctiernan's predator or die hard
where the muzzle flashes are almost a
character in the movie
so for reference go look at pre-digital
motion pictures like scarface like
predator like die hard
which have muscle flashes in various
environments and all of those are
really captured in camera and it gives
you a really good sense as to
the visual cues as to what muzzle
flashes should look like
in real life one of the typical
stumbling blocks
is forgetting about exposure when you're
shooting out in in daylight your
aperture is is really closed so those
muzzle flashes which may have been
photographed in a dark stage against
black
they may be completely overexposed super
hot white
in real life in the daylight they
wouldn't be
that hot super bright so you have to
treat them more like fireballs like you
might actually see little tendrils of
fire there are a lot of trip ups that
can happen with compositors adding
muzzle flashes
and one of the questions is do you use
the same texture
no you don't because each muzzle flash
is a snowflake each one is slightly
different because these are organic
fireballs that are happening in front of
the prop gun
my tip is you know please be aware of
your exposure
values for your shot go easy on the glow
and take cues from the rest of the film
and see what kind
of diffusion and filtration is happening
in the rest of the movie
because if that isn't happening in the
rest of the movie you don't want to have
all this diffusion in your muzzle
flashes
and three take it easy on the
interactive light especially on dark
scenes because
you have to nail the interactive light
which is painting pretend
light onto the frame or onto the actor
on the edge of the gun or
various set pieces that is being
illuminated by
the muzzle flash because that can get
out of hand really fast
and it could look really fakey i saw it
five times asks
so here's a question for animators and
animation studios
when working on theatrical long
sequenced visual effects projects
are you given a certain amount of pages
or minutes to work through
and then another studio gets a certain
amount and so on
in the best case scenario one visual
effects house would be working on the
entire film
that way the director and the visual
effects supervisor can work directly
with the teams
that's how a lot of the movies right up
until about the year 2000s were
accomplished
but movies became much more complicated
no one facility could take on that much
work
in that particular time frame so the
work started to get broken up with
superhero movies for example
we can split up the work in terms of
characters let's say there's five
superheroes in the movie
they each have five very distinct powers
we can safely
in most cases split up the work
of each individual character to a
different facility
what that allows is that facility can
focus on
the atmospheric effects of somebody who
control weather
another person is handling the flying
effects of another character
another one is handling the creature
effects where this character is an
entire creature
another way is locations and
environments
if you're having a big sprawling science
fiction movie where you're visiting
a desert planet and you're visiting a
jungle planet in the middle of the same
movie
one facility can handle all the shots in
the jungle
and then separately the the desert
battle sequence another facility can
handle that but it's a tricky thing and
it requires
a great deal of scrutiny from the
the film's visual effects supervisor to
make sure that stylistically all of
these shots which are done by
many different studios from around the
world
all feel like the same movie
stylistically from the same vision
serving the director's needs brit asks
i'm watching civil war i'm assuming they
mean
captain america civil war for the first
time and
how did they de-age robert downey jr
what is this devil magic one of the
techniques is what i call the grafting
technique
the actor in present day their current
age
performs the scene just as they would
any other scene
with the other actors under the regular
studio lights with the movie camera
and they perform as the younger version
of themselves then
a very carefully cast uh
body double comes in and is photographed
sometimes saying the same lines and
going through the scene
to see how shadows and light work on
them how bounce light
is affecting their faces when you come
back
to post-production artists go in and
find frames and sequences that are
appropriate to
graft and remove and graft and put onto
the recipient it is a
laborious frame by frame artist
driven technique other techniques that
you could use
are a partial computer graphics version
of it where
instead of using the grafting uh
technique of warping
real photography onto the acres you go
completely computer graphics for parts
of the head or parts of the face
then the next step would be full
computer graphics from
from head to neck or head to toe in some
cases
including the costumes because at that
point
you may want to change the performance
or you may have to change the
performance
so there's a lot of different routes
there's a lot of different ways to get
there
most importantly it's what is driving
the performance
and how to maintain the integrity of
the director and the actor and what
they're trying to get across
finally deep fakes the tech and the
techniques and the workflow is still in
its infancy
it's going to be used in feature films
and there are other techniques that are
on the horizon
that are showing incredible promise
machine learning ai
driven deep fakes and it's just a matter
of time till
this becomes a tool in our in our chest
that we can use them
use all of these tools or
interchangeably even right now
to get the shot across but it is still
very time consuming it still has to be
filmed
with a level of planning and detail
that is really really extensive and even
in the near future these things require
an army of artists and technologists a
great deal of planning
there's also performance level
uh considerations that have to come in
mind
do you want the older actor performing
as the younger actor
does the older actor in the present day
know how the younger actor moved
physically
is it going to be driven by the literal
performance on the day
or is it going to be driven by a
performance in a studio
in a more controlled environment there
are still so many questions
it is hard for me to envision a time
where it's as easy as casting
a younger actor and filming your movie
and framing your movie
in such a way to have another actor play
the younger version
of your main character one thing that
will always be coming up against
and battling is the human being's
ability to recognize
human beings our emotional essence
of how our eyes work how our brains work
how we relate to one another
is built upon this vast memory bank
of understanding how real humans
look emote and act why we praise the
best actors in the world
usually isn't because of all of their
gesticulation or some
you know sometimes that is the case
where a big brash performance
gets a lot of acclaim but in other times
it's because of the soft subtle
movements and facial tics and gestures
that to untrained eyes like that's not
acting that's just being human aha
yes that is being human doing this stuff
simulating this kind of stuff is very
hard
and that's why some call it the holy
grail of computer graphics or
visual effects it is very hard to
convince
humans that the synthetic human is a
human
because of the massive amounts of
complexity that is required to convince
you that this is real
will mccrabb asks vfx artists who are
parents
when you watch movies with your kids at
what point do you let them see behind
the curtain
and tell them how it was done i have two
kids we show them a lot of movies
it's similar to if you go to a really
great magic show
and you're just wowed by the magician
and
you know of course human nature is how
did they do that
if someone came up right next to you and
told you immediately how they did that
it would ruin a little bit of the fun in
cases where the kids like
the movie more the more likely i am to
wait to tell them anything about the
making of the movie
but the older they got the more
interested they would get as to how
these things were done
i would slowly introduce them to
uh the techniques that are used but in
the cases where they do ask
like literally hey dad how'd they do
that i will
walk them through it sometimes it's
really eye-opening and they they really
love it and they think that's well
that's really really interesting
or sometimes they i will lose them
entirely and they'll just walk off and
want to play minecraft
these were really great questions thank
you for letting me answer them for you
this has been vfx support